intervient car de l'eau rtement la
servier pourquoi à la serviette va jouer
un grand rôle dans la dégustation de
l'auto là et encore y en a qui sont bien
plus fortement pour les déguster ça j'en
suis sûr parce que moi j'en mange pas
assez souvent quand même mais la
serviette sert à cacher lorsqu'on a
l'ortolan dans la bouche parce qu'on a
la bouche pleine de grèce et au retour
l'arrêt très gras alors on a tout la
grèce qui dégouline dans la bouche
et puis derrière la serviette on peut se
concentrer davantage on peut se régaler
apprécié déguster vraiment voir ce qu'on
a dans la bouche c'est une chose qu'on
ne peut pas avoir souvent et on va en
profiter au maximum
voilà alors là je vais commencer à
marcher mon art hogan
alors je le prends et c'est tortola îles
et brûlant n'est ce pas alors je le mets
et voyez-vous contre la joue elle échoue
je ne souffle pas et parce qu'il
pourquoi un soufflet pour l'attendre et
on est là ça y est envoyé j'éprouve je
commence déjà à voir de la grèce faire
la figure c'est ça qui est pas joli
alors non je n'ai mendois se mettant
déguster
ces chants puis la chose qu'on ne
devrait pas refaire et qui n'est pas
très joli je commence à le prendre
l uçk us ces dernières au monde à mercy
huit buts et ce que j'aime a rejoint
d'importants chaud
c'est bon vous dire que je vous ai
construit à ma place je vous assure si
vous pouviez avoir ce que moi j'ai je
suis que renta je suis sûr de berger
sera devant vous mais mes vraies marges
je suis avez vous de tout coeur est avec
vous régalez vous avec moi en même temps
que c'est bon
vous assurez absolument à tous les vents
ma tête c'est c'est pas comparable à
rien mais je vous assure
le plan c est peut être celui minière
rio minier capam amaury pourra mourir ou
d'une coop que se racontent elles
et bien non il vient non c'était pas le
cinéma c'était la dégustation d art
alors les ordonnances et le roi des
gibiers le gibier des rois vous avez
déjà eu l'occasion laurence de déguster
des ortolans à la serviette avec autant
d'actualité non non ne pas dire des
rôtis serait pas que j'y aille je crois
mais c'est un